When using transparency for materials we set the color's Alpha
value to specify an object's opacity. You might have a red
material and the Alpha is used to make it semitransparent.
When used for texturing, we often think of the Alpha as
the amount of coverage. For example, to create a cut-out
leaf, you could specify for each textile whether the leaf is
visible or not. An alpha of one or zero. However,
you can get a better result by specifying an alpha between
one and zero for textiles on the edge of a
leaf. Each edge textiles Alpha represents how much the lease
covers that particular textual. For example, this textile was covered
by 6 10 of a leaf, so its alpha would
be 0.6. What's interesting here is that a single alpha
value is used for both opacity and coverage. It can
even mean both at the same time. You could have
a cut-out figure whose textile has a 0.6 coverage and
a 0.7 opacity to get a 0.42 alpha. Whatever
the interpretation, we use the same over blending equation
when putting one object the top another. Using alpha
for coverage is a simplification. For example, when we have
just alpha value, we don't know the true area
covered by an object. Combining a few coverages together
is something of a best guess when we use
blending. This is usually a fine assumption under normal circumstances,
where only a few pixels have multiple overlapping edges.